The following
content is provided
by MIT OpenCourseWare under
a Creative Commons license.
Additional information
about our license,
and MIT OpenCourseWare
in general
is available at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: Vasily.
Vasily Strela who works
now for Morgan Stanley,
did his PhD here in the math
department, and kindly said he
would tell us about
financial mathematics.
So, it's all yours.
GUEST SPEAKER: Let me
thank Professor Strang
for giving this
opportunity to talk here,
and it feels very good to
be back, be back to 18.086.
So, a few more
words about myself.
I've been Professor Strang's
student in mathematics
about ten years ago.
So after receiving my
PhD, I taught mathematics
for a few years.
Then ended up working for
a financial institution,
for investment bank, Morgan
Stanley in particular.
I'm part of an analytic modeling
group in fixed income division.
What we are doing, we are
doing math applications
in finance and modeling
derivatives, fixed income
derivatives.
That's actually what I'm
going to talk about today.
I want to show how 18.086,
it's a wonderful class
which I admire a lot,
which applications
it has in the real world,
and in particular in finance
and derivatives pricing.
Let's start with
a simple example,
which actually comes not
from finance, but rather
from gambling.
Well, let's look at
horse racing or cockroach
racing, if you prefer.
Suppose there are two
horses, and sure enough,
people bet on them and
bookie is a clever one, very
scientific-minded
guy and he made
a very good research of previous
history of these two horses.
He found out that the first
horse has 20% chance to win.
The second horse has
80% chance to win.
He is actually right about his
knowledge about chances to win.
On the other hand, general
public, people who bet,
they don't have access
to all information,
and the bets are split
slightly differently.
So 10,000 is placed
on the first horse,
and 50,000 is placed
on the second horse.
Bookie, sticking to his
scientific knowledge,
splits the odds 4 to 1, meaning
that if the first horse wins,
then whoever put on the
horse gets his money back
and four times his
money back on top of it.
Or if the second horse wins then
whoever put money on this horse
will get the money back
and 1/4 on top of it.
So, let's see.
What are chances for bookie to
win or lose in this situation?
Well, if the first
horse wins then he
has to give back 10,000
plus 40,000, 50,000,
and he got 60,000,
so he gains 10,000.
Well, good, good for him.
On the other hand, if
the second horse wins,
then he has to give back
50,000 plus 1/4 of 50,
which is 12,500, so
62.50 altogether,
and he loses $2,500.
After many runs, the expected
win or loss of the bookmaker
is the probability
of the first horse
to win times the expected
win, plus the probability
of second horse to win times the
expected loss, which turns out
to be exactly zero.
So in each particular run,
bookie may lose or win,
but in the long run he
expects to break even.
On the other hand, if he
would put the chances,
he would set the odds according
to the money bet, 5 to 1.
what would be the outcome?
Well, if the first horse wins he
gives back 10,000 plus 50,000,
60,000, exactly the
amount he collected.
Or if the second
horse wins, again, he
gives back 50 plus 1/5 of
that, 60, he breaks even.
So no matter which horse
wins in this scenario,
the bookie breaks even.
How bookie operates,
well he actually
charges a fee for
each bet, right.
So the second situation is
much more preferable for him.
When he doesn't care which horse
wins, he just collects the fee.
Well here, he may
lose or gain money.
This is quite
beautiful observation,
which we will see how
it works in derivatives.
So now back to finance,
back to derivatives.
So we are actually
interested in pricing
a few financial derivatives, and
what is a financial derivative?
Well, a financial
derivative is a contract,
payoff of which at
maturity, at some time T,
depends on underlying
security -- in our case,
we always we will be talking
about a stock as underlying
security, and probably
interest rates.
What are the examples of
financial derivatives?
Well, the most simple example
is probably a forward contract.
Forward contracts is a contract
when you agree to purchase
the security for a price
which is set today --
you've agreed to purchase
the security in the future
for the price agreed today.
Well, for example, if you needed
1,000 barrel of oil to heat
your house, but not today, but
rather for the next winter,
on the other hand,
you don't want
to take the risks of waiting
until the next winter
and buying oil then, you would
rather agree on the price
now and pay it in the
future and get the oil.
What the price should be?
What is the fair price
for this contract?
Well, we will see
how to price it.
Well, the few observation here
is that this line represents
the payout -- it's always
useful to represent the payout
graphically.
This is just a straight
line because the payout
of our contract is
S minus K at time T.
This actually gives the current
price of the contract for all
different values
of the underlying.
Usually, the price of
the forward contract
is set such that for the
current value of the underlying,
the price of the
contract is zero.
It costs nothing to
enter a forward contract,
so that's why it
intersects zero here.
What are other
common derivatives?
Another common derivative
are calls and puts.
And I put European
call and put here.
Don't be confused by
European or American.
It has nothing to do
with Europe or America,
it has to do with the
structure of the contract.
European basically
means that the contract
expires at certain
time T. American means
that's you can exercise
this contract at any time
between now and future.
We'll be talking only
about European contracts.
So European call
option is a contract
which gives you the
right, but not obligation,
to purchase the underlying
security at set price K, which
is called strike
price, at a future time
T, which is expiration time.
So if your security at
time T ends up below K,
below the strike,
then sure enough
there is no point of
buying the security
for a more expensive price.
So the contract
expires worthless.
On the other hand, if your stock
ends up being greater than K
at expiration time
C, then you would
make money but my
purchasing this stock for K
dollars and your payout
will be S minus K,
and this is a graph
of your payout.
This line here, as we will
see, is the current price
of the contract, and
we'll see how to obtain
this line in a few minutes.
Another common
contract is a put.
While call was basically a
bet that your stock will grow,
right, the put is the bet
that your stock will not grow.
So, in this case, the put is the
right, but not the obligation
to sell the stock for
a certain price K.
Here is the payout, which
is similar to the put,
but just flipped.
This is the current
price of a put option.
Calls and puts, being
very common contracts,
are traded on exchanges --
Chicago exchange is probably
the most common place for
the calls and puts on stocks
to trade.
I just printed out
a Bloomberg screen,
which gives the information
about a few calls
and puts on IBM stock.
So I did it on March
8, and the IBM stock
was trading at this
time at $81.14,
and here are descriptions
of the contract,
they expire on 22nd
of April, so it's
pretty short-dated contract.
They can go as far as two
years from now, usually.
Here is a set of strikes,
and here are a set of prices.
As you can see, there
is no single price,
there is always a bid and
ask, and that's how dealers
and brokers make their
money -- like a bookie,
they basically charge you
a fee for selling or buying
the contract.
That's how the money are made
-- they are made on this spread,
but not on the price
of the contract itself,
because as we will
see in a second,
we actually can price
the contract exactly,
and there is no uncertainty once
the price of the stock is set.
There are plenty
of other options.
Slightly more exotics
contracts, either digital
which pays either
zero or one depending
on where your stock ends up.
It probably is not
exchange-traded,
also I'm not sure.
There are hundreds,
if not thousands,
of exotic options where
you can say that, well,
how much would be
the right to purchase
a stock for the maximum price
between today and two years
from now.
So it will be past-dependent.
Depending on how
the stock will go,
the payout will be
defined by this path.
There are American
options where you
can exercise your option any
time between now and maturity,
and so on and so forth.
So, just before we
go into mathematics
of pricing, just a few
observations and statements.
First of all, it
turns out that thanks
to developed mathematics,
mathematical theory,
if you make certain assumptions
on the dynamics of the stock,
then there is no uncertainty
in the price of the option.
You can say exactly how
much the option costs now,
and that's what
provides, and this
is a big driver for the market.
So dealers quote these contracts
and there is a great agreement
on the prices.
The price of the
derivative contract
is defined completely
by the stock price
and not by risk preferences
of the market participant.
So it doesn't matter what
are your views on the growth
prospects of the stock.
It will not affect the price
of the derivative contract.
As I said, so the
mathematical part of it
comes into giving the exact
price without any uncertainty.
So let's consider a
simple example now.
Let's assume that we are
in a very simple world.
Well, first of all, in our world
there are only three objects --
the stock itself, the
riskless money market account,
meaning that it is an account
where we can either borrow
money or invest money
at the riskless rate r,
and finally our
derivative contract.
Here we are not making any
assumptions of what kind
of derivative contract it
is -- it could be forward,
it could be call, it could
be put, it can be anything.
Moreover, our world is so
simple, that first of all,
it's discrete,
and second of all,
there is only one time step
to the expiration of power
of contract, dt.
Not only there is
only one step left,
we actually know exactly what
our transition probabilities.
There are only two
states at the end,
and we know the
transition probability.
So with probability p, we
move from the state zero
to the state one, and with
probability of one minus p,
we move to the state two.
And just notice, because this is
riskless money market account,
it's the same in both cases.
You just invest money and it
grows with risk-free interest
rate.
So, what can we say about the
price of our derivative f?
Well a simple-minded -- well,
let's start with the forward
contract.
We know what the payout in
delta t of our forward contract
will be, it will be just the
difference between the stock
price and our strike.
Well, a simple-minded
approach would be -- well,
we know the transition
probabilities,
let's just compute the
expected value of our contract,
and that's what we would expect
to get if there were many such
experiments.
Well, you take the probability
of going to state one,
you multiply by the
payoff at stage one.
Take, minus p for probability
of going to state two,
multiply by the payout
in that state two.
Sum them up and you
get the expression.
As I said, the common
thing to choose
the strike such
that the contract
has zero value now, so
you get your strike.
Well, in particular
you could say
that if you research
the market well
and you know that the stock
has equal probability of going
up and down, then actually
you expect your strike
to be an average of end
values of the stock.
But as we can imagine,
following our bookie example,
this is not the right price.
There is actually
a definite price
which doesn't depend on
transition probability.
Here is the reason why
there is a definite price.
Well let's just consider
a very simple strategy.
Let's borrow just enough
to purchase a stock.
So let's borrow S_0
dollars right now and buy
the stock for this money.
And let's enter the
forward contract.
Well, by definition forward
contract has price zero now,
so we enter the
forward contract.
Now, at the time dt when our
contract expires, what happens?
Well, we deliver our
stock, which we already
have in our hand in
exchange of K dollars.
That's our forward contract.
On the other hand, we
have to repay our loan,
and because it was
a loan, it grew.
It grew to S_0
times e to the r*dt.
Now, let's see.
What would happen if K
was greater than S times e
to the r*dt?
Then we know for sure,
we know now for sure,
that we would make money.
There is no uncertainty
about it now.
Similarly, if K is
less than this value,
then we know that
we will lose money.
That's not how the
rational market works.
If everybody knew that
by setting this price
you would make money, people
would do it all day long
and make infinite money.
So there will be no
other side of the market.
So the price has to go down.
So the only choice for K, the
only market-implied choice,
is that K has to be equal
to S times e to the r*dt.
As you can see, it doesn't
depend on transition
probabilities at all.
That's what market implies us.
That's the price of
forward contract,
and that actually
explains why, when
I was plotting the
forward contract,
current price was just
the straight line,
it's just discounted payoff.
The payout is linear, so just
the parallel to the payoff.
That's the idea, basically.
The idea is to try to find
such a portfolio of stock
and the money market
account with such a payout ,
which will exactly replicate
the payoff of our derivative.
If we found such of a
portfolio, than we know for sure
that the value of
this portfolio,
the replicating
portfolio today is
equal to the value of the
derivative, because otherwise,
you would make or
lose money risklessly.
That's no-arbitrage condition.
So, can we apply it to our
general one-step world?
Well, if we have a general
payout f, what we want to do,
we want to form a
replicating portfolio such
that at expiration time, it
will replicate our payouts.
So we want to choose such
constants a and b that such
that the combination of
stock and money market
account in both
states will replicate
the payout of our option.
Then, if we are able to
find such constants a and b,
then we just look at the
current price of the contract
and it has to be equal
to the current price
of our derivative.
Well, but in our particular
case, this is easy.
It's just two linear equations
with two unknowns, easily
solved, and here is current
price of our derivative.
No matter what payout is --
I mean you just substitute
the payout here, and if you
know S_1 and S_2, that's it.
A useful way to look at this,
just to re-write this equation,
is in this form, and then notice
that actually the current price
of our derivative can be
viewed as a discounted expected
payout of the derivative, but
with very certain probability.
This probability,
it doesn't come
from statistical properties of
the stock or from any research,
it actually is
defined by the market.
So it's called a
risk-neutral probability.
So this probability
doesn't depend
on the views on the market
by the market participants.
An interesting observation
is that actually,
the value of this stock, the
discounted value of the stock
is actually also is expected
value of our outcomes
under this risk-neutral
probability.
That's basically general idea.
Now let's move one notch
up and try to apply
these idea to continuous case.
Well, if you live in
continuous world now,
we need to make some assumptions
on the behavior of the stock.
The very common assumption is
that the dynamics of the stock
is log-normal.
Log-normal meaning that
the logarithm of the stock
is actually normally
distributed.
So, here mu is some drift, sigma
is the volatility of our stock,
and dW is a Wiener process,
W is a Wiener process
such that dW is
normally distributed
with mean zero and
variance square root dt.
Our approach would be to find
the replicating portfolio.
And what does it mean?
It means that we want to find
such constants, over time dt --
so we assume that a and b are
constant over the next step,
dt -- such that the change
in our derivative is a linear
combination with this constant
of the change of our underlying
security and the change
of money market account.
Now we just need to look more
closely at this equation.
First of all, let's
concentrate on df.
So, f, our derivative,
is a function
of stock value and time.
But unfortunately, our
stock value is stochastic,
so df is not that simple, and
to write df out we have to use
a famous -- Ito's formula
from stochastic calculus,
which actually is analogous of
Taylor's formula for stochastic
variables.
Let's see.
If our S will not
be stochastic, if it
would be completely
deterministic
and depend only
on dt, then there
would be no term and
differential f is just
the standard expression.
On the other hand,
if we have dependence
on stochastic
variables, then we have
to have more terms,
and why this happens?
Well, in very rough words
is that because the order
of magnitude of dW is
higher than dt's --
it's square root of dt.
So we have to make into
account more terms,
and in particular, we have to
take into account next order
of dS squared.
Formally, dS square can
be written this way,
and again, very rough
explanation is as follows.
If we would square
this equation there
will be three terms there.
One would come from the
square of this term,
and this would be of
the order of dt squared,
next order of magnitude
-- much smaller than dt.
The second term will be
cross-product of dW*dt.
What order of magnitude
we are talking about,
it is dt to the power 3/2,
again, much smaller than dt.
On the other hand, the third
term will be the square of dW,
this is of order
of magnitude of dt,
so that's what we have to keep.
And that's what Ito's
formula is about.
Now, we are basically,
we know all terms here,
and let me stress out that this
term, dB, it is not stochastic,
it's completely
deterministic because we
know that B grows with the
rate r, that's what it is.
So we substitute all those terms
into our replicating equation.
We collect the terms.
We get this equation.
And again, there is
the deterministic part,
there is stochastic part.
So the only way for
this equation to hold
is this term to be equal
to this term, and this term
to be equal to this term, and
that's what's written out here.
So again, two equations,
these two unknowns, and here
is answer.
Finally, let's take
a*S to another part.
Notice that this
part of our equation
is completely deterministic.
So we know how it will grow.
So basically, d of f minus
a*S, which is b times dB,
is r times b times dt.
And we know all other
terms, we substitute them
here, take something
to the left-hand side
and get this equation.
So this is partial differential
equation for our derivative f,
as a function of S and
t, of second order,
and this equation is the
famous Black-Scholes equation.
It was derived by Fischer
Black and Myron Scholes
in their famous paper
published in 1973.
Myron Scholes and
Robert Merton actually
received Nobel Prize
for deriving and solving
this equation in '97.
Black was already
dead by the time.
This is really the
cornerstone of math finance.
The cornerstone is because
using the replicating portfolio,
using this reasoning, we were
able to find an exact equation
for our derivative.
So a few remarks
on Black-Scholes.
So first of all, we
made some assumptions
on the dynamic of the stock, but
we never made any assumptions
on our derivative.
Which means that any derivative
has to satisfy this equation,
and that's very strong
result. So if you
assume that our
stock is lognormal,
which is not a bad assumption
and agrees quite well
with the market, then we
basically, in principle,
can price any derivative.
We know the equation
for any derivative.
The other thing is that
our Black-Scholes equation
doesn't depend on
the actual drift mu
in the dynamics of our stock.
So again, it is the manifest
of risk-neutral dynamic.
Not only we wrote down the
equation for our derivative,
we also found a
replicating portfolio.
So in other words, we
found a hedging strategy,
meaning that at
any given time we
can form this portfolio
with rates a and b.
If we hold both the derivative
and both replicating portfolio,
altogether, this
is zero sum gain.
We know that no matter
where stock moves,
we will not lose
money or gain money.
So if we just charge
bid-offer on the derivative,
if we charge a fee
on the contract,
we can hedge ourself
perfectly, buy the contract
or sell the contract,
hedge perfectly ourself
and just make money
on the fee, that's it.
Finally, more
mathematical remark
is that actually after a few
manipulations, a few change
of variables, the Black-Scholes
equation comes out
to be just a heat
question, which you already
saw in this class.
This is very good news.
Why is this good news?
Well, because heat equation
is very well studied.
So the solutions are well-known,
and numerical methods, the ways
to solve it, in particular
the numerical ways
to solve it are well-known.
So we are in business.
But as any partial
differential equation,
the equation itself doesn't
make much sense because to find
a particular solution we need
boundary and initial condition.
And although any derivative
satisfies Black-Scholes
equation, the final
and boundary conditions
will vary from
contract to contract.
Here are a few examples of the
final and boundary conditions.
Here, an interesting
remark that if, usually,
we would talk about
initial condition, here
we are talking about
final condition.
The time goes in
reverse; we know
the state of the world at the
end, at expiration, not today.
So, here are final and boundary
conditions for call and put,
and let's look a little bit
at the pictures for our call
and put to see where
they come from.
So for example, for calls, well,
this is our final condition,
right, this is
defined by the payout.
On the other hand, the boundary
condition, well, what happens,
we put them at zero at an
infinity, we [INAUDIBLE PHRASE]
to put them at
zero and infinity.
And why?
Well, because if stock hits
zero then it stays at zero.
That's what our dynamics show.
So the value of our contract
at maturity will become zero.
On the other hand, if the
stock grows, grows to infinity,
a good assumption to
make is that actually it
becomes similar to stock
itself, so it would just
become parallel to the stock,
and that's the conditions
which we impose here.
Similarly for the put, you
can derive these conditions.
And again, just because
it is a heat equation,
it turns out that for a simple
derivative such as the calls
and puts, it is possible to
find an exact analytic solution.
Here are exact analytic set
of solutions for a call, put
and the digital contracts.
Well, not surprising
again, I mean
they're all connected
to the error function,
so to the normal
distribution, basically,
as the solutions of heat
equation ought to be.
Why do they look
exactly the same?
If we have five
minutes at the end,
we'll probably shed some
light on the specific form
of equations.
But let me just stress that we
can see that it's discounted,
and what I'm claiming, it's
expected value of our payout
under risk-neutral measure.
Here is an example -- it's
of a particular call option
on the same IBM stock.
So I chose the
short-dated contract,
just to avoid the
dividend payment.
So it's a contract
expiring on March 18.
So there is 10
days to expiration.
The stock, as we saw,
the expirations of stock,
as we saw, is what's
trading at 81.14.
The volatility is
somewhere around 14%,
estimated either from other
options or historically.
Here is the price
of our contract.
I also have a simple
Black-Scholes calculator here,
and let's see if we
can match this price.
So let's see, I believe the
volatility was 13%, right,
13.47.
The interest rate,
it's already here.
As we all know, Fed just
bumped the interest rate,
so they are at 4.75% right now.
The strike of our option was 80.
Time to expiration
was actually 10 days,
and this should be measured
at a fraction of year.
So we divide 10 by 365.
This stock was trading at
81.14, if I'm not mistaken.
Here is the price of our call
options contract, which is 150.
Well, it's within the offer.
So maybe our
volatility's slightly off
and if we increase
[UNINTELLIGIBLE] to say,
increase it to 14%, it
will go slightly up.
152.
Well, in general, let's
play a little bit with it.
Well, it is very
short-dated option,
so the value of our option
is very close to the payout.
So if we increase
the time to maturity,
let's make it two years
just to see where --
so now value of our option is
-- well, that's what it is.
If increase volatility, sure
enough, let's make it 30%.
So what do we expect?
We expect if volatility is
higher, the uncertainty higher,
so the value of our contract
should go up, and it sure does.
So basically that's how
Black-Scholes works.
And plenty of those
contracts trade
on the market, but unfortunately
not all of these contracts
are so simple as calls and puts.
First of all, there are many
more complicated products
with more difficult payout,
which will constitute different
and probably discontinuous final
conditions on our Black-Scholes
equation.
Moreover, we made an
assumption that the volatility
is constant with time,
and interest rate
is constant with time.
It is certainly not
true for the real world.
Volatility probably
should be time-dependent,
and this would make
the coefficients
in our Black-Scholes
equation time-dependent.
Unfortunately, these cannot
be solve analytically.
So in most of the
cases in practice,
we will have to use some
kind of numerical solution.
Finite difference methods
is the typical approach
for the heat equation.
As you know, both explicit
and implicit schemes,
and you will discuss
some of those in 18.086.
Tree methods.
Tree methods meaning that we
go back to our one-step tree,
and basically assume that
our time to expiration
is many time steps away and
we'll grow the tree further,
so from this node we
have two more nodes,
and so and so forth.
That would imply the final
condition at the end,
and discount back using our
risk-neutral probabilities,
and get the price now.
So those are called
tree methods.
One can show that actually those
tree methods are equivalent
to finite difference -- explicit
finite difference schemes.
Those are very popular.
But again, in tree methods,
what is very important
is to set the probabilities
from your tree, the transition
probabilities, to
the right ones,
and the right ones are
risk-neutral probabilities.
Probabilities implied
by the market, actually.
Another important numerical
method is Monte Carlo
simulation where you would
simulate many different
scenarios of the development of
your stock up to the maturity,
and then, basically
find -- using this path,
you will find the expected
value of your payout.
But again, in order
for this expected value
to be the same as the
risk-neutral value,
as the arbitrage-free
value, you have
to develop your Monte
Carlo simulations
with risk-neutral probabilities.
So, risk-neutral valuation
is extremely important.
Here is actually the general
risk-neutral statement, which
one can prove, is that actually,
the value of any derivative
is just discounted expected
value of the payout
of this derivative
at maturity, but you
have to take this expectation
at the right measure.
Using the right measure, meaning
that you have to set correctly
the transition probability
-- you have to make them
market-neutral.
Under this measure, actually
the dynamics of our stocks
looks slightly different,
and as you can see,
our drift becomes
the interest rate.
So under risk-neutral
measure, everything
grows with our
risk-free interest rate.
Just to shed a little
bit of light on how we go
at the solutions
for calls and puts,
Black-Scholes solutions
for call and put,
well this is the
distribution of our stock,
log-normal distribution
of our stock at time T,
and if we take this distribution
and integrate our payout
of our call option against this
distribution -- in other words,
find the expected value of
payout of our call option under
risk-neutral measure,
then, sure enough,
you will get
[UNINTELLIGIBLE PHRASE].
This illustrates the best
-- because what is digital?
Digital is just the
probability to end up
at above the strike
at time T, right?
So if you integrate
this log-normal pdf
from the strike K to infinity,
that will be your answer.
This is a good exercise
in integration,
to make sure that it's correct.
So let's see.
To conclude, what we've seen.
So, we have seen that modern
derivatives business makes
use of quite
advanced mathematics,
and what kinds of
mathematics is used there?
Well, partial differential
equations are used heavily.
Numerical methods
for the solution
of this partial differential
equations are naturally used.
In order to get these
equations, we actually
need to operate in terms
of stochastic calculus,
meaning that we need to know
how to deal with Ito calculus,
Ito formula, Girsanov theorem,
and so on and so forth.
The other thing is to be
able to build simulations
to solve the heat equation
and all other equations
that you might encounter.
The topic which we
didn't touch upon
is statistics because,
of course, very advanced
statistics is used
for many, many things,
for analyzing
historical data, which
can be quite
beautiful for trading
strategies and many others.
Besides these five topics,
there is much, much more
to mathematical finance,
which makes it a very, very
exciting field to work in.
That's what I wanted
to talk about.
Thank you very much
for your attention.
PROFESSOR: Maybe I'll
ask a firm question
about boundary
conditions, because you
had said that
those are different
for different contracts.
And how do you deal with them
in the finite differences
or the tree model or whatever?
What would be a typical one?
GUEST SPEAKER: Well, typical
one -- two very typical ones.
So those, you basically
make a grid of your problem,
in particular, you
build a tree, which
is actually a grid of
all possible outcomes.
You set them up at the
end, so your tree grows --
so you set your boundary here
at the end, and well, you set,
probably, some initial --
this is final condition,
so you set some boundary
conditions here.
So this is your time T. This
is t = 0, time t -- this is 0,
this is 1, this is 2, this is
T. So you set your payout here,
so it will be maximum
of S minus K and 0.
PROFESSOR: How many time
steps might you take in this?
GUEST SPEAKER: Well, you would
do like daily for three months
-- if you three-month options.
PROFESSOR: Maybe 100 steps.
GUEST SPEAKER: Yeah,
something like that.
Well, if it's two-year option,
that you probably would do it
weekly or something like that.
PROFESSOR: You don't
get into large,
what would be scientifically,
large-scale calculating.
PROFESSOR: No, in
finance we usually
don't keep this problem--.
PROFESSOR: In
finite differences,
do you use like higher-order
-- suppose, well,
you had second derivatives,
would you always use second
differences or
second-order accuracy?
GUEST SPEAKER: In general, yes.
In general,
second-order accuracy.
In general you don't go higher.
I mean the precision -- well,
it's within cents, right.
So you cannot do
better than that.
So it depends -- well, it
depends what kind of amount you
are dealing with.
If you're actually selling
and buying units of stock,
you might consider
something more precise.
But it's very problem-defined.
So that's how we deal with it.
PROFESSOR: Any questions?
You can put the mic on
if you have a question.
STUDENT:
[UNINTELLIGIBLE PHRASE].
GUEST SPEAKER: Well,
it is Markov process.
Yes.
I mean, this is just
a numerical solution.
So yeah, it is Markov process.
and basically all
stochastic calculus
is about Markov process,
continuous Markov process.
PROFESSOR: Is the
mathematics that you
get involved with pretty
well set now or is there
a need for more
mathematics, if I
can ask the question that way?
PROFESSOR: Yeah,
well, in this field
it is probably quite well set.
But if you get into
more complicated fields,
especially into credit modeling,
the model for the credits
of certain companies, then
mathematics is not quite set,
because there, you start
talking about jump processes
and not Wiener processes, not
just log-normal processes.
This stochastic differential
equation become very hard,
but maybe still
analytically tractable.
So from this point of
view there is need --
but it's not a
fundamental mathematics,
it's not that you are
opening a new field,
but definitely trying to solve
a stochastic differential
equation -- which usually
boils down to solving a partial
differential equation
analytically --
can be pretty hard a
mathematical problem,
viewed as a
mathematical problem.
PROFESSOR: So you
showed the example
of Black-Scholes solver.
Everybody has that
available all the time?
GUEST SPEAKER: Oh yeah.
On Chicago trading
floor, the traders
have calculators where
they just press a button
and it's just hard-wired there.
PROFESSOR: And they're
printing out error functions,
basically -- a combination
of error function, yeah.
GUEST SPEAKER: Well, sure
enough, nobody uses just --
I mean this was very approximate
example and that's why I chose
such short-dated stock, that
before it pays any dividends,
and where we can assume
the volatility is constant,
and so on and so forth,
to match the prices.
Otherwise, the prices
wouldn't match.
PROFESSOR: Thank you.